hi friends on last week's episode we
discussed how people can become addicted
to social media how cognitive biases
that we don't know even exist in our
brains are being manipulated by almost
every social media that exists and how
your phone is essentially a hacker in
your pocket the feedback this week's
been absolutely fantastic I've got so
many tweets and messages from people
saying that they are trying to reduce
their phone time and this has helped to
open their eyes to why it's not
necessarily their fault this week I'm
sitting down with caiway who is the CEO
of the light phone calm and they think
that they have developed a product which
can enable us to spend more time
off-screen I do think that there's an
important question to be asked here and
it is can we fix the problem of too much
technology with more technology that's a
question you'll have to answer yourself
also I do want to say that I was not
sponsored or paid to interview Kai and I
found him off my own back because of how
interested I was in the product and I
wanted to hear his philosophy on it I
also want to say that I'm considering
buying one after my conversation with
him but that's completely independent so
here we go
kai way
[Music]
so hi welcome to modern wisdom very good
to meet you thanks for having me thank
you very much for kudamon you are CEO of
the light phone that's correct so I got
introduced to the product from a friend
who just linked me to online and I had a
I had a browse around and it seemed it's
a real a real unique device as far as I
can see for those people who think here
those people who think that technology
is sort of moving in one direction which
is more more functionality more
integration with our lives and you guys
have come up with a product which kinda
goes in the complete opposite direction
do you think that'd be fair to say yeah
I see a lot of press mentioning us as
anti smartphone but you know we always
wanted to clarify that we're not
anti-technology all anti smartphone
which is trying to you it will be more
humid about how we approach technology
specifically the smartphone that we all
have 24/7 yeah I understand that so can
you give us some background background
to yourself and how this concept came
about yeah of course so my background is
in design and design research four years
ago away five years ago I quit my job
and joined this incubator that Google
started in New York specifically for
designers just because you know they
think the hypothesis is studying
designers when you put this on as I'm
the founding table without the tada we
created with empathy can really create
social impact so we were my co-founder
Joe and I met in a space and we were
encouraged to do mobile app you know
just like any other startup yeah so but
very soon that we realize for both of us
creating another app it's the last thing
we want to do and we were doing research
about how human how people interact with
equipped with smartphones and we just
kind of freaked our self out like I'm
sure you see this everywhere not just in
New York you know in subway in trend
station an airport everyone is looking
80% of times looking down this it
doesn't matter who are they with or
where they are you know I did this
swiping away on the screen we we know
that we check our phone to hundred eyes
or more than six hours a day is that the
other end is that the average figure
yeah that's the average speakerphone on
the research that we can slide to every
hour
200 times a day and six hours a day on
arch I mean with teenagers even warts
with social media that you know could be
on their smartphone ten hours a day it
is not human our perspective we can
really stare at the screen 24/7 well
that's crazy
I mean I'd seen them I'm not sure how
much truth there is in this by read a
quote from an article that said
something like in one week
humans get more stimulation more visual
stimulation than they would have gotten
an entire year typically during the
revolution and you know it you are right
to look at it to step back a little bit
from typical smartphone use and look at
it as a
an alien I suppose looking down on earth
you have all of the all of the
complexity and the beauty and the the
uniqueness of day-to-day life going on
and where we all spend so much time
staring down at our phones so what what
year was this when you first went into
the into the project it's in 2014 you
know we we start we started to utter
research we started to thinking about
how do we create something that create a
physical object that could encourage and
inspire more people to take a break so
can you know just like you said like we
go ahead no no just can you take take us
through the research that you did on
into people's phone use can you explain
how that was conducted and who it was on
and what it consisted of yeah of course
I just so he basically ignited random
random people friends we know and we
take away their smartphone for say like
six hours or in pilot day and we keep
them you know a flip phone at a time and
ask them to spend a whole day or six
hours without their smartphone and then
what's interesting is that I was that
when they came back from the trip or
after the day you know like they have
come and come and feed by that the first
half hour of first hour was extremely
difficult is you have this anxiety that
you don't know what to do this knows
nothing on me I can't I can't pull pull
pull out my smartphone start swiping
I'm getting bored what do i do what do I
do like everyone that reaction in the
first 20 30 minute minutes however
what's magical is is that after you get
over there or more you know the feel
missing now I'll feel yeah yeah once you
get over to that what's what's gonna
happen is you you started to pay
attention to to other people to the
building to the cloud you know like talk
to strangers sometimes when you're
waiting for a bus or waiting for subway
it is fascinating and they report back
it's like you know either I have a lady
beacon back saying that's the best day
of the whole week just because she
remembers what happened during the day
like literally absolutely I think
there's definitely a a parallel that is
run between how much you how much of
your day has been spent on your phone
and how not mindful you have been
throughout the day not anyone who is
undergoing mindfulness practice and
trying to be more present in the first
the first place to look I think that
we'll be able to improve your ability to
be present is to want to put your phone
down because by its very nature having
your phone out and in your hand is not
being present you're not where you are
you're somewhere else in a virtual space
yeah we got a lot of you know feedback
when we started life on you know like
the most logical common question would
be hey why do I need life oh right I'll
just turn on flight mode I'll just you
know leave my smartphone at home why do
I need like I our apps out there that
that could limit notification or turn
off notification you know that isn't
that isn't that you know possibly it's
achieved some purpose not that life I
was offering and my answers always be
that we I think we as human we need
object to inspire fashions and I think
that's how it's also how religious work
you have all kinds of books and starters
and make lists they just need something
to to inspire you to encourage you to
take actions yeah
you can also say hey why can I use a
bowl of flip phone nokia phone 20 years
ago and my arguments okay so how many
people that you know actually do that
yeah
now many it's not special I know one
really do that because the experience of
using those advantage devices are not
special all we're trying to do is
creating object a brand and our brand
message to make
disconnecting to make you know stay away
from smart ball special yeah so more
willing if you take a break you know not
not trying to replace my phone saying
hey you smartphone it's bad yeah don't
use your smile at all we're not saying
that we're just saying hey you know it's
like we have different shoes different
clothes for different occasion your
smartphone is great for emails for
FaceTime your family or gaming whatever
that you want to do social media but
what if sometimes all we want to do is
you know take a walk down the street or
spending two hours with your family in
the park or just you know be creative
try to concentrate or just sitting on
the beach watching sunset why do you
need a mini computer with you all the
time yeah I think that's that's a really
good analogy to say about the different
clothes because you're right we have our
loadout so to speak to using a gaming
analogy is different based on what the
situation is that we're going into you
know we were different clothes and we
have a different backpack to go to the
gym versus to go to the office versus to
go away on holiday and you know when
you're talking about a piece of a piece
of technology which takes up up to six
hours of your day so you know not far
off a third of your waking life is spent
on this one object making more more
appropriate for the situation gearing
that in the same way as you do your
outfit and your bags and your food and
everything else you know it you you are
right it does seem like a like an odd
thing to not be doing so let's let's
roll back so you've taken people's
phones off them during your your
research the people who have had an
older phone with less functionality have
noticed that they have an improved
quality in their day was that the from
there on did that kind of kick off right
we need to try and do something about
this we need to try and mirror the
reduction in apps in a device
where did he go from that yeah pretty
much
we just find it fascinating that pretty
much everyone comes back saying that's
the best hours best tile it had the
whole week just because just because
we're being bombarded with so much
information all the time and we and I
think that's why we decided hey like
that's that's what we want to do you
know I mean if you look at a current
state of Technology right
everything that's everyone else Google
alcohol cents or whoever they're all
building product to move us to or more
come at your life but there's no
violence no one's offering a healthy
violence if attack we were to to offer a
better option yeah it why why you know
but the the other argument will be why
would they none of the none of the
companies inherently believe that there
is anything wrong with too much phone
use the attention economy and
advertising which is why is paving the
way for most of the apps that are on the
phones it's advertising time at the
entire on screen is what these people
are concerned about so if you can make a
device which goes longer and more
immersively and is more seamlessly
integrated with your life that's more
time on screen that's better
right you know that from one side of
defend this that's the way that they're
gonna presume whereas it would appear
that what people actually value in terms
of what they consider to be time well
spent is time off screen yeah I mean I
think it does exactly what in my opinion
that's that's a huge it's almost at
crisis of human even they like we are so
blindly willing to give up what we have
in front of us but give out our thoughts
give up board and that you know boredom
is supposed to be feeling bored it's how
you you be creative how you you know
look into yourself and start a
conversation with it with yourself but
right now because of attention business
because of all the business model in the
app not smartphone app all of it smart
is trying to grab your attention well
your time so they can make money out of
it they can either you know putting more
advertisement or Lu you to subscribe
service there's nothing wrong with that
that's how company work but the problem
is like when everything is doing that
your device is just it's it's not it's
we're putting ourself in at this at this
advantage as a human absolutely we are
vulnerable and I think one of the big
one of the big things I listen to what
kind of got me onto this this topic
specifically was a podcast that Tristan
Harris from time well-spent did with Sam
Harris halfway through last year and I
know that that was really eye-opening
for a lot of people and for me to see
that and to look at the persuasive
techniques that are being used by app
developers and the companies that are
behind some of the the most highly used
and highly engaged social media sites in
the world it feels it does feel like
you're being tricked it did I know that
it's not that there's some evil cabal of
people in hooded robes sat behind you
know in some black dungeon somewhere
that's not the way it is but it kind of
it kind of does feel a little bit like
that you know as a user you you kind of
this rat in a maze getting getting
forced around this app loop and you know
you before you know it you've spent 45
minutes in bed on a morning and you're
late to make breakfast and you you late
to go and do the things that you
actually want you to do with your day
because you've been stuck in a loop yeah
and as a designer it's like when you
know what we design habit we were to
design app you always want to make sure
like every step away it's enticing you
create this page the next page I all
make sense
oh interesting so people spend more time
on your app that follows through
complete your process you know as a
designer that's how we design before if
we're designing at that's how it is I
have and that's why please help this is
following app benefit from it too
which is so vulnerable as human that I
think with light for now we wanted to
also know start a conversation oh you
know why can we have different options
right why can why can we up our with our
smartphone edges you know use something
else so that we won't be hijacked we're
using something that that actually
designed to respect us you know it's not
designed to grab your time attention or
you know make you spend more money on it
they just want to sell you something
yeah welcome
what can we design something beautiful
and that respect humans time yeah I
think I think what's interesting is that
this there's kind of two two sides to to
looking at this or three sides should I
say to looking at this at this problem
as far as I can see one of them is what
Tristan Harris appears to be focusing a
lot of his time on which is coming at it
from an ethical design perspective so
he's trying to have a change in the
culture on a designer's side so that
they're thinking about what they're
doing with the apps I think on another
side there is tactics that normal people
and normal smartphone users can use in
terms of reducing their time on screen
or improving the quality of their time
on screen and then there appears to be a
third a third side of that which is
looking at solutions to the smartphone
you to smartphone use overall and I
think that to me that appears to be
where the like phone fits in yeah I mean
I think Tristan's approach is very
interesting and then he might be able to
create might be able to create a long
turn the impact but in my opinion you
know it's it's tough it's the business
model that drove the addictiveness of
our app it's not a designer so I did if
if there's not you know if business
model is not trying to force you to
spend more time enticing you spend more
time they make money designer won't do
that because they won't you know usually
designer is following what company's
policy and they're usually not the one
making the final decisions so you're
saying you're saying that for as long as
the attention economy is driving revenue
through time on screen the app
developers are going to continue to do
that so all they're doing is meeting a
brief right yeah and you also have an
app you just within the ecosystem the
smartphone app a it will be so there's a
psychology study we know we are learned
that the only the presence just the
presence of your smartphone on the table
changed our conversation you were made
if I'm if I'm sitting right across you
and I have my phone out that changed our
conversation because we you would both
expect our conversation world will be
interrupted we will pick up our phone
and text and look at you and talk in the
same time we will look at look at a
notification like I think just the
presence of your smartphone really
change our behavior that's so
interesting yeah it's crazy how
smartphone people immersed into our
daily life and it's also fascinating how
we are not fighting back yeah yeah for
sure for sure I think what's really
interesting is you said they're having a
smartphone out on the table you're not
the first person who's cited this
actually use if one of the co-hosts
mentioned this on a previous podcast
really funny that you've both come up
with the same story but it's really
interesting smartphone is such
ubiquitous part of our lives but yet in
the same sentence having it out changes
our behavior so that shows that although
it's accepted it's not natural if it was
natural it wouldn't make any difference
but it's not it's it is an impingement
it is a restriction on our time and on
our normal discourse yeah because this
is so addictive like you you can't we
all have this nervous habit to just
check it
every couple minutes every couple of
seconds it is but extremely powerful
over have so much power over us yeah we
just don't we just feel like we need to
do something else to to help out I agree
I agree indeed but yeah like you say
it's the tristen's approach from time
well-spent in the Sun of human
technology both of those check them out
if you're listening and the links will
be in the description below those are
important important systemic changes but
they're a cultural change and I do think
that that's going to come about through
understanding through disseminating
information and you know you are right
that the the economy at the moment is
driving people in that direction so it's
not it's not a fix which can be reached
very quickly I don't think that it's the
sort of solution which is going to
manifest itself or its its destination
should I say which is going to be
reached very quickly yeah I mean I
obviously wish that that could bring
like immediately impact as well I think
we as human we need we need to fight
back and with life phone I think our
philosophy when we started designing
designing it and creating a vision we
don't we don't really seem like so as a
solution to smartphone addiction the
life on to us it's actually it's a
question that was host to our users what
is the question the question is when you
go out with lights on you have no
smartphone you have no social media no
game no message no notification what are
you gonna do what's important in your
life what are you gonna think about
we're gonna talk to you when you get
bored what's what's essential to you
like I make I think all this profile
question that we right now especially
nowadays that we have smartphones all
the time you just you know take it out
and spending died on it we forget it do
all that I think that's like so
important to us as human to to really
have time creating vironment creating
the time for us to you know have a
conversation with ourselves I think I
think I know I think they're having a
conversation with yourself is is such a
really important message
we were we were discussing in life hacks
101 one of the the podcasts that we
recorded not so long ago we discussed
that during meditation and mindfulness
practice a lot of the time when you
quieten down the mind you end up having
thoughts and ideas that come to you and
they never come to you at any other time
of the day I lack quick that's
absolutely due to the fact that you do
not have this distraction this barrage
of of stimulus that's taking you away
from being with your thoughts and taking
you into a world that you've seen a
million times before the images are
different and maybe the texts different
but the experience is the same do you
know I mean yeah that's that's what make
us human I we we just we can't forget
about it this that's why we're human
we're not not AI were not you know
machine like we we we ask ourselves
stupid questions we ask ourselves silly
questions we get bored yeah we we get
jealous we get it yeah like that's so
important to humanity
so actually we we you know it's being
three years since we start a life phone
we we have 10,000 users around the globe
and now we're asking ourselves how do we
encourage people to go light more often
go light meaning leave your smartphone
and go out uh-huh
how do we do that more but how do we
stay away from smartphone yeah so we've
talked with dust we've danced around it
can you take us through what the light
phone is from bottom to top
yeah so technically like phone there's a
query cross-eyes mobile song now only it
makes and receive phone calls as nothing
else I'm have no messaging notification
no internet no social media so how he
works is that you basically pair like
song with your smartphone and when you
want to use life phone you could turn it
down like phone crying smartphone leave
your smartphone behind and go out
without all the distractions and noise
so you you are able to enjoy the moment
and be more present but with someone
calls you on your smartphone the code
will get forwarded to your lights on so
you won't miss important calls Academy I
guess no distraction don't always bright
I understand so I've done a little bit
of a little bit of reading and how to
look around
am i right in thinking that you're
allowed to call 9 people is that right
yeah we allow user to save up to 9
speed-dials our life oh so you got the 1
to 9 and the keypad and you can call the
1 through 9 as outgoing calls
yes that's that's the initial intention
the reason how we make that design
choices that doing research when we ask
people to go out with you know leave
your smartphone behind and go I would
Swiss for old mobile phone we also ask
our participant to write down the
numbers they may eat for the day and no
one has more at 6:00 but no one has
counted number one or more than six no
one has like why do we have thousand
can't get enough oh yeah that's why we
make that decision yes so right you are
so right I think the top probably at the
top 20 people that you call the there
would be or of your entire phone book
you're right that 95 percent of the
people that you're gonna call most
regularly are going to be a very small
number of phone numbers and some of
those are probably gonna be pizza
deliveries and takeaways and stuff like
that so so okay okay so I'm right in
saying that you keep your own number as
well right so it's not a separate phone
it's kind of like an extension of your
existing phone yeah we we offer that
cool cool masking feature in u.s. only
so in the US when you get like phone you
could you know pair like phone with your
smartphone and and the life of all
basically use your smart phone number so
when you make phone calls on life long
it will still shows out that you're you
know it's you not a different number
yeah okay so what is the roll out at the
moment of light phone where is it
available and where is it functioning
yeah we we ship internationally and at
the moment I think we should roughly
10,000 plus like phones to 50 different
countries whoa
and it is amazingly like we we learned
this problem is so universal it was not
just us or UK it's like everywhere
especially in Asia conscious - okay
and we were in Hong Kong Airport like
when we you know meaning I have when I
went to Hong Kong to meet some players
we saw the stickers everywhere in the
airport that asked people to look up
because it's become safety issues
everywhere in Airport it was just like
staring their phone bump into each other
other what it's such a big issue people
looking at the phones
that it's an actual safety hazard it's
been classed as a safety hazard the
people aren't looking up as opposed to
looking down yeah it's easy yeah we all
have so much in lighting our life by a
friend's family you know like trees
cloud building's the architecture is
beautiful a store is like but we just
will and we give it give those Oh up
okay you're really right I think
something that one of my um one of my
work colleagues said to me about a year
ago on a similar similar subject and he
asked what was the last three things
that you liked on any social media yeah
and if the listeners can try and do that
if unless they've got the phone in front
of them now if you can try and think
about the last three things that you
click like on an Instagram or Facebook I
have absolutely no idea how did you know
those those things were so worthy of my
time that I sacrificed some of my life
to go on to this device and look at them
and then give a judgement of positivity
in response to it and yet upon being
asked to recall it 20 minutes later I
can't even tell you what it was yeah we
just we think so quickly it just we
don't you know we don't really spend
time just hang you just flip the through
we have so much information all the time
really yeah it's it's it's almost such
an information overload as people go
through through the phone that the depth
of interaction has to be by very nature
shallow in order to
fit the breath of consumption in do you
think that's fair to say
totally and and I also think it's
because it's easy we always we you know
we human will always want we're lazy we
want easy way out that's why I live
smarter when you feel challenged when
you feel awkward when you feel bored yes
you have a way out same thing with
social media same thing with anything
like when you have a difficult or you
just want to you know instead of like
really dive into it really like think
about it you just go blindly consuming
information without even thinking about
it yeah the boredom the boredom thing is
a really interesting one as well
I'd seen a study online that said
something like more than 60% of people
admit to using their phone on the toilet
and I honestly saw that and thought is
it only 60% like I don't know anyone I
don't know anybody that goes to the
bathroom and doesn't take the mobile
phone with them like yeah and down that
bathroom thing is such a big deal like
you know that's the one time where you
probably can afford to be alone with
your thoughts and with you know what I'm
gonna swipe through Instagram and we're
doing all all bits and pieces like that
you think oh yeah yeah the boredom is
part and parcel and the silence is part
and parcel as well and I think that the
rates of anxiety mental health and
suicide is the number one killer of men
in the UK under the age of 40 you know
rates of anxiety to mental health week
this week actually in the UK and in a
society where we're trying to reduce
anxiety reduce depression and I'm going
to guess that there will be some studies
that I'm not aware of is smartphone use
and smartphone use been scientifically
linked with anxiety and depression yet
or are you aware if it has I am NOT but
I might we always believe that be more
connected war-makers any happier looking
at people's feet or make you happy
it is gonna
make you more anxious you're gonna
compare and for for teenagers for young
people that didn't we didn't really
realize that you know the social media
or internet just one site of just one
small angle of this person's life thank
you you see you know you see like oh I'm
always pondering on my face patterning
on Facebook I'm always out traveling on
my Facebook or Twitter or social media
but that's not real life that's just a
reflection of one angle of this person's
life I see as human we always want to
show the positive side always want to
show that we're laughing we're having
fun no one no old saying on Facebook
saying who my boyfriend just dumped me
on my groceries oh hey I had a really I
had or even on the other end of the
scale like you know at least at least
that's interesting no one is going on
and saying nothing really happened today
today was a little bit dull I think no
it's not it's not newsworthy is it but
there's a really good quote that I read
and I reiterated this on a recent
podcast that said social media shows you
the best of everybody else's lives
whilst you view the worst of your own
and you compare it to the worst of your
own it's the best of everyone else and
yeah no it's not at all man so going
back to the light phone I think what was
what's interesting is there's a couple
of a couple of big podcasters that some
of my friends follow who do either a
phone free afternoon or they have
actually created a rudimentary version
of what the light funders by getting
like old you know a pay-as-you-go the
10-pound Nokia phone and they've tried
to cobble together a solution like this
and a couple of the issues that those
guys have come up against so one of them
what the problem with not having a phone
on you at all is that I think there's
definitely a level of safety of knowing
that you've got your phone with you like
you know you there may be an emergency
either you needing to contact someone or
someone needing to contact you I think I
think going completely phone-free holds
so much anxiety for some people that
whatever level of freedom they would
gain by not having their smartphone
would be nullified and then probably
actually even made worse by [ __ ]
their pants that something bad had gone
wrong and that they weren't able to be
contacted or that they couldn't contact
someone so I think going completely
phone free because phone free isn't the
issue is it the phone isn't the issue
it's the overuse and it's the immersion
in apps that data for that's the issue
phone is just a tool it's supposed to be
a tool it's not an entertaining you know
social media device it's a tool that you
use to talk to people people to
communicate with people you know and
that's why we want to do like yeah you
are exactly right that going completely
for free it's it's dangerous because
what if you don't want to you know
wanted to run to something I need to
call people what if it you know he some
emergency happened and life onto us
we install is creating a peace of mind
when you go out without smartphone so
you know almost knowing that hey I could
call my family if I need you
my you know my son's can reach out to me
if they want to but I didn't ask nothing
else I uh I was just recently had a
conversation with a woman in our working
space and she was telling me that life
is like a quarter I'm not sure in the UK
it's go Corey with Corey the $0.25 going
yeah yeah yeah so it's like a calling
all day I said why it's like a quarter
and she was like because you know in the
old days without smartphone you always
want to have a quarter on you so you can
use that info just in case you need to
make it yeah that's such a good analogy
yeah that really is and then I think it
so the second that say the second
solution that a couple of people come up
with was to get like a you know like you
did with the
during your study you gave people like
an old flip phone but I think another
one of the issues is when you're asking
people to make a lifestyle change like
this it needs to be as convenient as
possible it has to stack the deck in the
favor of doing the thing that you want
them to do and obviously if you one of
my friends tried to do this in the UK
and he got a 10 pound pay as he ghost
pay to go phone then realised that
because he's got a micro-sim from an
iPhone he then asked to go and buy an
adapter to make the micro sim into a
normal sized sim so that he can fit that
into the phone and that means like
taking his iPhone apart every time he
wanted to do it taking the back of this
old phone taking the battery out you
know fitting it into fitting it into the
new like micro sim adapter and putting
it in and you just think well I'm not
surprised that he only stuck up with it
for like one day a week for three weeks
because I couldn't be bothered to do
that it's not gonna it's not gonna be
nian and the thing is that the disparity
between moving from a situation of such
hyper convenience with Google Maps and
Wikipedia and Google on you know on a
device to think right not only if I got
to give this up but I've got to get
through all of these really shitty
hurdles fiddly hurdles to give myself
less functionality it you know it
doesn't surprise me that that that
wasn't a very successful approach yeah
like I said it's not special enough for
you to actually want to do it I mean to
successfully in encourage people to to
to stay away from smartphone I mean I
think that's why we create a life on
it's well-designed buildable so you
might you know for people that the never
thought about going going out with their
smartphones
might it might good tree can say hey
this thing goes cool I'll go I'll go for
sure
it looks aesthetically the smart the
light phone looks really really cool
it's just a little bit bigger than a
credit card right yeah it's a coracle
size and it's a bit thicker
then the actual query car but it's easy
it's for you to put in wallet just
pocket so you don't actually feel it's
on you yeah that's that's the purpose
when we design LIFO
try to decide what's that phone factor
we you know we try to think about what
is that thing what is the thing that we
always have on a spoon we don't really
notice that we have them it's a credit
card ID if you're yeah so that's why we
make the design position you much you've
much time you've matched the phone with
something that already exists which is
the which is the credit card I think it
was interesting what you said at the
very start about it needing to be
something that was beautiful
that is kind of a little bit like
planting a flag in the ground so to
speak it's making a mark and it's you
you are attaching you're attaching your
desire to go phone free and to do less
tech usage to something which you can
almost feel proud of a little bit you
need your help oh you have something and
you feel proud of it and you think oh
this is this is a physical
representation a manifestation of my
desire to better myself and to be more
present
yeah I feel I mean it's it's reflected
on her users as well like I feel really
proud or honor that a lot of our
customer that who bought a light phone
like they share like these almost they
shared the the moment would he get
lifelong and and they just feel proud
obviously sharing on social media is
kind of ironic but you can see that the
proud that you know they want to share
that hey I decide to do something I I
make this choice I'm gonna live this
life from time to time
I'm gonna use my life own type of time
call me if you need me like we see a
happening a lot of social media people
sharing life um with their friends is
just fascinating to me like it's almost
become a lifestyle symbol I want to say
and we just
and feel that I think what we want to do
is just to encourage more people to try
to do that you know to try to stay away
from what you would never do like no one
does that
so we want to you know just hopefully
inspire more people go away to to try
different solution different shoes
different clothes why not yeah I think
that I think the different shoes and
different different outfits analogy is
the best one that I've heard so far I
think that what was interesting is you
know there's an argument to be made that
fixing the problem of too much
technology with more technology seems a
little bit a little bit circular but
that's like saying that there is a
problem with riding a bike so why buy a
car or why have a pair of walking shoes
it's the same yeah it's within the same
realm but it's a different a different
route to meeting a similar goal Thanks I
mean we we like different shoes
different clothes they said how we
always say it
we were always you know like if you
compared life onto your smartphone
smartphone it's like you know it's like
tool box again it's like it's all kinds
of tool you could sort of to where you
don't need yeah and my phone is a
screwdriver so you could choose what do
you need we can choose what technology
we need in a specific condition
situation we don't have to take it all
in we need to make a conscious choice
the right now is no choice it's all
smartphones everyone's making smartphone
everyone's having smartphone 24/7 it's
the last thing you see when you go to
that if this is not addiction what what
is it I think that's I think that's a
really good point to be made the
it is your right it's the last thing
that we look at before we go to bed it's
the first thing that we look at in the
morning it's there it was there was a
video that got put up the other day of a
girl's 21st birthday and there was it
was a snapshot of her birthday cake
coming over to her in a nightclub and as
this cake come along and obviously
someone spent a lot of time making this
cake and organizing this big procession
to arrive with her and the camera pans
round to her sat on this table and she's
watching her own 21st birthday cake
arrived through the lens of her phone
because she's so desperate to get the
Instagram story to put up about that and
you think we've all been there like
we've all done something you know video
in a gig or oh yeah videoing a concert
or you know something beautiful that was
happening but you know who's it for
because the memory of that happening for
you will be much more valuable than the
video that gets shown to your friends I
know I just it's like you go to accounts
for everyone's putting it on recording
and blocking your view I mean every time
I happened god I was like God watch the
concert yeah there's a there's a really
funny meme that I saw that was floating
around on the internet and it said
something like I was sat down on the
subway looking at the man across from me
and he didn't have his phone out he
wasn't sat there texting or swiping
through Instagram he just sat there
looking out of the window like a
psychopath anything that's such a
comment on modern society that that's
that's the weird thing to do
yeah that reminds me of a story a story
uh yeah it's a story so so me and my
co-founder we a couple years ago we were
in San Francisco doing this you know
retail relationship things anyway we we
were in lying in from a restaurant and
the lighting follow us is a that
his daughter and his daughter just you
know keep shouting and screaming saying
I don't want to be here this is bored
I'm bored I'm bored I don't want to be
here so typically you were expecting you
know your dad just like give her a smart
phone your iPad something to take our
attention away but he didn't do that
he sat her down and actually say that
hey we talked about this for them is
that she can Stu learn I was like I need
a videotape this this is so good yeah
expect him to say anything like that but
like wow I need to give you a life all
right yeah for sure
well you know I think that that man's
daughter has got a good chance of
growing up to be a very mindful and a
well-balanced human being who's going to
be able to deal with awkwardness she's
going to be able to deal with her
emotions coming to the forefront with
sadness and it's not going to need
numbing or hiding away by it by getting
behind a phone so like phone at the
moment I'm right in saying that you guys
you guys raised quite a lot of money on
on Kickstarter projects right yeah we D
so three years ago we reached 400,000
Kickstarter and then we go on raised
another three million from private
investor just to your thighs it's still
hurtful they are building a font on
scratch like from two individual it just
not easy or not oh no I can't no it's a
small undertaking so three and a half
million dollars
yeah pretty much went into it and
especially with all that design
background so we want to make sure like
I'm packaging on its phone itself on
cable it's all you know design may well
because it's an exploration it can be a
shitty cheap eternity ins like it is
throwaway burner phone it can't be it
has to be beautiful it has to be
expiring the packaging till we I'm not
sure if it's not the packaging that we
did it's a book yeah we have seen it if
anyone if anyone hasn't if you say
online it's absolutely beautiful you
know we wanted to you know tell people
that would get like phone you get
impression that it's not about feature
not about screen size it's about a
little moment of your life that if you
put on a smartphone now you will notice
you know like a picture of bird are
flying through top of tree a picture of
old man sitting on the beach you know we
want to tell people hey my phone's not
about phone
obviously we're selling a phone but it's
not about a song it's about the value is
the value of life on it leave your
smartphone behind go out enjoy your day
enjoy your time like you know enjoy
enjoy time when it passed through like
just don't don't occupy yourself your
thoughts with with feet yeah sure it's
weird isn't it cuz the the light phone
could probably be replaced with the life
phone you know you you're allowed you're
allowing yourself to have life as
opposed to a phone yeah so so where
where where is the so the phones
functional like fully functional with
the call forwarding and everything in
the US am i right is what about Canada
what about Europe what's the what's the
plans moving forward to make this more
accessible for people in other countries
well we actually 50% of our customers
are from either international users also
for international users you can still do
coke forwarding the only the only issue
the problem that you know if you know
you don't have as international user is
that we won't be able to mask your life
phone number so you will you essentially
have two different numbers uh-huh
but people you can help when they call
in
it'll forward on to the light phone so
that kind of doesn't matter and then on
the outgoing calls there's only maybe
nine people that need to have your
second number in any case right yeah and
then we we were like we were worried
that this will be a you know like stop
international customer from you know
buying like four or using like phone but
to my surprise is not really of changing
the decision so like I said fifty
percent of our customers are wrong
UK EU Asia different countries too but
amazing I think that you know the a lot
of people have identified that time away
time off screen even if they haven't
looked into this and I'm talking like
normal everyday person on the street
hasn't delved down the rabbit hole of
persuasive of cognitive biases and
persuasive techniques and you know time
on screen reduction and all that the
normal person I think appreciates that
they're using the phone too much what's
natural is you know there's only really
two options it's either go form free or
kind of get a burner phone and neither
of those are tremendously attractive so
when the only hurdle that you do need to
overcome is to have a second number to
me that doesn't feel like a tremendously
big a tremendously big problem because
you you were at the very least you were
gonna have to have a second number
anyway for the the pay-as-you-go Nokia
23 tans that you were gonna look to use
as a replacement
yeah I go so potentially get a deuce in
car to Sin Cara with same number I think
I believe Vodafone or other carriers
Europe does all for that so Chris I'll
feel bad if I didn't mention it we are
actually launching life on to today
no way yeah today on IndieGoGo they did
the stance is you know it's being ten
thousand songs and three and a half
years like I said we keep asking
ourselves how do I make it how do we
encourage people to go light longer to
go light for good you know not a pair
secondary device but how do we do
something that that encourage a lot more
people to go life okay that's fun all
right so come on tell us tell us what
like phone to tell us about like phone
to I'd dial up see no idea that this is
happening
yeah so if I use the same analogy that
smartphone is a toolbox life song one
it's a screwdriver life on two it's a
Swiss Army knife - okay stop the light
phone - I'll go is to position it as
your primary phone it's not a second
phone I pay with smartphone we wanted we
want to have this device to potentially
replace your smartphone it's a full G
critical sites on the same the same song
factor we add link as the display and we
are gonna sit like a Kindle right Clark
yes like we can do black and white
beautiful UI simple UI we had messaging
to the second generation we are also
potentially adding the ability to cover
and alarm clock direction but that's it
we're not gonna do like we're not gonna
become small company is to us it's us
with Swiss Army knife phone that I think
a lot of people will be globally are
ready to make the switch so
you when you say messaging you talking
SMS yes there's a mess okay so do you
see smartphone 2 as being a replacement
for smartphone 1 or do you see it as
being an alternative like you'd have a
different scales of an other like a car
and a scooter they perform the same task
but people don't necessarily some people
will want one and some people will one
another yes exactly that we're not we're
not you're not replacing like someone
which is you know just because we got a
lot of customer emailing out saying hey
I love life's on one but can you just
add text message I want to use like
phone all the time but without text
message or Direction ability because
actually I can you know go lie all the
time can use in a daily tool and and
that's exactly how a position like for
one you know if life on one is a taker
breaks phone it's a vacation phone it's
as long you use when you're sitting on
the beach watching sunset yeah oh we
life on two we want to create a a
different option that hey for those
people weren't ready
cue to give up smartphone give up give
up being a slave of technology this is a
this is a option is not it's not always
cool Nokia or scroll model it's eating
display query concise with all the
essential tool that you need in your
daily life yeah
what do you think do you think that you
guys are at risk of receiving criticism
from people who who think that it's a
just a nefarious route to try and sell
another piece of technology to people
maybe but we actually we have you know
we when we started life on to what you
did a survey asking our customer hey do
you do you think you will be you know
HIPAA quiz with us to try and you to the
Swiss Army knife tool and 80 percent of
customers saying no because they believe
that adding adding more features and
allow them to stay away from the smart
phone longer without social media
so internet without all the distractions
it's it's actually put your PO in this
so the X are the extra features net a
positive yeah it's it's it's essential
to like I said we're not trying to
become a smartphone oh I want to do is
to invite more people to stay away from
me the sun's from this you know many
computer we have with us 24/7 we don't
need that we we have our iPad we have
our desktop with life on - you can
basically do anything else on your
laptop iPad pad and you have your iPhone
to four-course messaging going taxi
alarm clock that's it yeah I understand
completely
I think it's been absolutely fascinating
Chuck I would you be able to explain
where everyone can find you so the
original iPhone where the where the
campaign for the new ones going to be
and how they can contact you online
yeah if you could check out why phone to
back home that's where our campaign is
and you can find our website through the
campaign as well even I'm happy to you
know answer any questions from your
listeners my email is scary way at the
light phone that comes Casey I don't
yeah the like on the comm fantastic Chi
I really really appreciate your time on
am I am I right in thinking are you guys
in stock for the light from one at the
moment are you waiting on a new batch to
be delivered for shipping yeah we
actually sold out our life on one we
have no inventory left at the moment so
we be taking reservations for life on
one at the moment and we also taking
reservation or life on to a new life on
to calm amazing thank you very much for
your time Chi really appreciate that
links to everything will be below in the
description
good luck with your IndieGoGo campaign I
really do think that what you're doing
is born of a place of goodwill I know
that the there is a a criticism to be
made fixing too much tech with more
Tech is not a solution but I don't think
that I don't think that you guys are
trying to achieve a money-making
obviously it needs to be a commercially
viable business but I don't think that
you guys are are aiming to do this from
a place of bad faith I think that it is
genuinely something that's born of the
desire to make people's lives more
livable and I think it's a very noble
pursuit and I think that I hope that you
do very very well with it in the future
I appreciate it Chris thank you thank
you very much fun thanks for chain
[Music]